[Música]
boa tarde a todos
meu nome é bráulio então vamos falar de
tecnologia wan gang que não
hoje nós vamos falar de laços humanos
isso mesmo
é verdade que as empresas estão passando
por uma enorme evolução essa evolução
tecnológica
a empresa que não for para esse momento
que não for pra esse caminho com certeza
está fadado ao insucesso
mas é muito importante o pessoal que não
se esqueçam momento algum da importância
dos laços humanos
elas correm em paralelo
eu posso afirmar não vai existir empresa
seja ela com a ideia que for seja ela
com a tecnologia que tiver que vai
conseguir chegar no final que vai
conseguir bons resultados sem que têm
esses laços humanos e é disso que eu vou
falar hoje para vocês como vocês podem
ver eu estou no estilo moderninho se
possa dizer podem notar pela minha barba
e não pensa em que essa barba simples de
manter ela demanda no mínimo de uma vez
por semana de cuidados porque você tá
falando isso que foi legal
da mesma maneira que eu precisei
reinventar encontrar uma forma para
entrar nesse caminho do modernismo foi
necessário também que o profissional o
barbeiro mudar a sua forma de pensar
olha que loucura
o que a gente busca quando vai hoje num
no barbeiro se busca hoje um lugar clean
em um ambiente onde tem uma sinuca um
ambiente onde tem uma bebida um
refrigerante um suco um ambiente para
descontrair e esse profissional ele
precisou se reinventar de dentro para
fora para também entender que esse
ambiente merece um laço um laço um
ambiente familiar um ambiente como se
fosse um bar onde se encontram amigos
nos sábados durante a semana e que ali
você pudesse encontrar esse ambiente
gostoso que fizesse ter o prazer de
estar lá
que loucura não no mundo de
transformações no mundo de qualquer
melhor tesoura qual é o melhor corte
qual a melhor máquina e ao mesmo tempo
ser tão importante esse laço ea desse
laço familiar que eu vou trazer para
vocês hoje
antes eu queria pedir um exercício
simples de 10 segundos no máximo com
certeza você vai passar alguma situação
familiar em que ficou seja um ponto bom
ou seja um ponto ruim mas que de alguma
forma se passaram uma conversa mais dura
no feedback é aquela conversa ao pé do
ouvido de um pai e de uma mãe por um
filho
e é nesse ponto que eu vou trazer pra
vocês eu venho do interior de minas
isso mesmo uma cidade pequenininha nós
estamos falando de 16 mil habitantes
chama luz fica no triângulo mineiro
meu pai um leiteiro
mas não o dono da fazenda o cara que
buscava o leite chegava num caminhão
antigo caminhão velho chegava no geral
buscava aquela lata de 50 litros de
leite jogava aqui de cima do caminhão
até chegar na empresa para descarregar
minha mãe dona de uma loja pequena muito
pequeno muito simples linha mas nós
éramos muito felizes muito unidos
estavam sendo muito próximos
a minha irmã compõem a família
os dois irmãos meu pai minha mãe e uma
casa onde como vocês podem notar pela
foto
mesmo com a simplicidade em volta sempre
muito amor muito carinho e de e dante e
dentro desse carinho todo as
responsabilidades vieram e já os 13 anos
eu e minha irmã já eram os responsáveis
por buscar o leite com meu pai
no caso eu ea minha irmã era responsável
por ajudar a minha mãe na loja
claro que no primeiro momento quando meu
pai colocou vocês precisam de alguma
forma está envolvido não é no trabalho
da gente
claro que a minha primeira escolha foi
as o homem aquela coisa do interior vou
com você pai no caminhão buscar leite
irmã fica com a minha mãe
na questão de dobrar as roupas mostradas
a roupa na loja
poxa pessoal não preciso dizer quem vem
da fazenda quem sabe desse dia batalhado
como que é
não gastei três dias cheguei com meu pai
falei pai quer trocar de emprego quero
trabalhar com a minha mãe
no primeiro dia me pegou com uma lata e
50 de ti leite no geral baixo e me jogou
dentro do caminhão foi não estou pronto
para isso
não aguenta uma coisa dessa então eu com
isso eu vim trabalhar na loja
ficamos eu e minha irmã uma média de uma
hora e meia duas horas por dia mas tendo
a responsabilidade aprendendo um monte
de coisa que sempre que é possível
sempre que há um espaço eu uso até hoje
e dentro de si nesse tempo que a gente
foi vivenciando veio um ponto do meu pai
que ele queria que ele ficasse mais
próximo
ele tinha esse caminhão à noite à tarde
ele sempre fazia manutenção desse
caminhão e num no fundo de casa que
tinha e ele comprou um lote isso mesmo
ele comprou um lote e falou assim aqui
vai ser seu campo de futebol
porque eu quero que você fique mais
próximo eu quero que você esteja próximo
quero te ver
então com isso ele montou um campo campo
simples de traves de madeira não muito
grande cara aquilo era coisa mais
gostosa do mundo para saborear ante a
que determinava o trabalho terminava a
escola tinha ali mais de 40 50 meninos
montando o time e dividindo e julgando
era muito gostoso pessoal era muito
saboroso e ao mesmo tempo debaixo da asa
de um pai protetor de um pai do interior
de minas nessas entendem muito bem o que
estou falando
mas o tempo foi passando e se imagina um
menino de 13 anos dono da bola
o dono do campo aquilo subiu na cabeça e
no momento que a falta de um lado para o
outro time eu inverti o pênalti pro
outro lado queria bater o pênalti
se alguém não concordasse eu mandava
embora a bola era minha unha debaixo do
braço e tomava a decisão ali e isso foi
a conta
não fui ficando agradável e eu fui tendo
alguns problemas com os colegas e os
colegas foram diminuindo isso é normal
um certo conta o meu pai me chamou
acompanhando esses essas brigas essas
discussões dessa falta de de de divisão
ele me chamou pelo brown nunca legal eu
queria te propor uma coisa eu vou
colocar no fundo daquele campo eu vou
colocar um isopor e nesses opor
eu vou te dar um uma caixa de tachinhas
e você vai para cada dia que você não
foi legal para cada dia que vocês
fizerem alguém você vai começar a pregar
essas taxas mas com o intuito de começar
a deixar de empregar tachinhas cara
aquela primeira semana foi horrorosa
eu não parava de pregar taxinha e virava
o pênalti para o outro lado e não
atendia não respeitava não foi bom
eu chamei com ele ainda com um pouco de
vergonha falei 'pai as tachinhas
acabaram você tem mais
sobrou eu tenho mais mas eu queria te
pedir que a melhora começa a passar um
dia dois dias e empregar essa taxa tinha
me ajuda a ajudar e eu falei com ele
pode deixar eu vou melhorar ea partir
dali pessoal eu comecei a diminuir o
número de tachinhas foi diminuindo eu
comecei a entender que aquilo ali não
estava a chegando aonde precisava eu
comecei a ver um retorno diferente e num
certo dia eu chamo meu pai falou pai
hoje eu passei meu primeiro dia sem
pregar uma taxinha estou feliz eu também
achando que aquilo ali era a solução
e ele me falou o seguinte cara entenda
para cada dia que você passar sem pregar
uma taxinha você vai retirar essa taxa
tinha dali eu quero que você retire
todas as tachinhas até você conseguir
limpar mais um mês um mês e meio e por
assim foi assim foi o mesmo e mail enche
meu peito
chamei ele pai hoje
consegui hoje não tem mais nem uma
taxinha empregada no isopor muito sábio
muito experiente muito vivido olhou pra
mim falou o que se vê daqui lá do lado
onde ele mexer no caminho que você vê lá
hoje eu vejo um isopor sujo da poeira
aquele terreno mas não vejo mais nada
vamos chegar lá perto filho
na hora que a gente chegou perto
ele apontou me mostrou cada buraquinho
da onde eu tirei as tachinhas disse pra
mim brown e esses buraquinhos foi como
ficou cada pessoa que você desfez
cada pessoa que você machucou isso filho
não tem volta
a partir daqui você pode dar um novo
mundo dá um novo curso para forma de
você viver a partir daqui você pode
buscar uma união
a partir daqui você realmente pode ter
amizade diferente
os que ficaram machucados cara
guarde isso eles de alguma forma podem
cicatrizar
eles de alguma forma podem até passar
mas daqui pra frente cara não pensa
diferente
não faça diferente cuidado com suas
escolhas só e dali pra frente eu fiz
diferente
eu passei a pensar diferente eu passei a
a cuidar das pessoas diferentes
eu cheguei numa empresa ela estava
quebrada há três anos atrás ea primeira
mudança que eu fiz foi tirar a mesa a
sala do presidente não é porque você é
presidente de uma empresa que você tem o
direito que você pode estar separado dos
demais
nós estamos todos no mesmo jogo nós
estamos todos para as coisas boas e as
coisas ruins a minha sala se transformou
numa visão onde o centro com meus
diretores com minha equipe meus gerentes
somos todos da mesma raça da mesma etnia
não há diferença não pode haver
diferença e hoje quando me perguntam
muito sobre qual foi a minha base
a minha base foi minha família foram
esses ensinamentos por essa maneira de
pensar
vinte anos de vivendo nesse ambiente de
tecnologia especialista em gestão mas na
verdade hoje eu sou o filho do evandro e
vocês são filhos de quem a questão
levando de ensinamento para a vida
obrigado montes claros